einst als stricken der turnschuh träger
belächelt sind die grünen
spitzenpolitiker heute unter den
beliebtesten der republik
sie sind eine partei der gegensätze in
umfragen beliebt bei wahlen können sie
nicht immer liefern sie regieren in elf
landtagen mit aber stellen nur einen
ministerpräsidenten bei der letzten
bundestagswahl holten sie nur knapp 9
prozent bei der europawahl dagegen über
20 prozent der deutschen stimmen die
klimabewegung hat den grünen aufwind
verschafft aber zum anfang vierzig jahre
ist die gründung als
anti-parteien-partei her
1983 schaffte sie es zum ersten mal in
den bundestag
die wahlergebnisse blieben trotzdem
meist im einstelligen bereich
in umfragen dazwischen schafften die
grünen ist dagegen zum teil auf
höchstwerte 2011 nach fukushima kamen
sie deutlich über 20 prozent
aber die euphorie verflog wieder und
dann brachte die partei auch noch den
veggie day ins spiel und rutschte bis
zur nächsten bundestagswahl auf 8,4
prozent ab jetzt ein neues hoch seit
über einem jahr liegen die umfragewerte
um die 20 prozent ihr durchschnitts
wähler
jung weiblich gebildet urban doch sie
werden bei allen beliebt bei der
europawahl wurden die grünen
zweitstärkste partei bei den deutschen
wählern
einzig auf dem land vor allem im osten
sind sie schwach bei den jüngsten
landtagswahlen holte die partei in
brandenburg
10,8 prozent in sachsen 8,6 in thüringen
52 prozent und auch auf bundesebene ist
der funke bisher noch nicht richtig
übergesprungen
15 jahre ist es her dass die grünen
zuletzt an der deutschen regierung
beteiligt waren
mal sehen ob ihr hoch diesmal bis zur
nächsten bundestagswahl 2021 anhält